[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal es ist ernst
nehmen sie es auch ernst seit der
deutschen einheit
nein seit dem zweiten weltkrieg gab es
keine herausforderung an unser land mehr
bei der es so sehr auf unser gemeinsames
solidarisches handeln ankommt guten
abend der appell an der kanzlerin die
offenkundig in sorge ist allein dass sie
überhaupt eine solche fernsehansprache
hält jenseits ihrer üblichen
neujahrsansprache zeigt schon was
langsam auch den letzten noch der mann
sollte
wir sind in einem ausnahmezustand und
der wird nicht so schnell vorbei sein
auch das treibt die regierenden im
momentum was kann man einer bevölkerung
wie lange zumuten
umso weniger zwang und so besser und so
ist der appell der kanzlerin einer an
die vernunft panik hat die wichtigsten
auszüge ihrer rede zusammengestellt
liebe mitbürgerinnen liebe mitbürger das
corona virus verändert zur zeit das
leben in unserem land dramatisch
unsere vorstellung von normalität von
öffentlichem leben von sozialem
miteinander
all das wird auf die probe gestellt wie
nie zuvor
es geht darum das virus auf seinem weg
durch deutschland zu verlangsamen
und dabei müssen wir das ist
existenziell auf eines setzen
das öffentliche leben so weit es geht
herunterzufahren natürlich mit vernunft
und augenmaß
denn der staat wird weiter funktionieren
die versorgung wird selbstverständlich
weiter gesichert sein und wir wollen so
viel wirtschaftlicher tätigkeit wie
möglich bewahren
aber alles was menschen gefährden könnte
alles was dem einzelnen aber auch der
gemeinschaft schaden könnte
das müssen wir jetzt reduzieren alle
staatlichen maßnahmen gingen ins leere
wenn wir nicht das wirksamste mittel
gegen die zu schnelle ausbreitung des
virus einsetzen würden
und das sind wir selbst sowie
unterschiedslos jeder von uns von dem
virus betroffen sein kann
so muss jetzt auch jeder
und jeder helfen zuallererst in dem der
ernst nehmen worum es heute geht nicht
in panik verfallen aber auch nicht einen
moment denken auf ihn oder sie komme es
doch nicht wirklich an
niemand ist verzichtbar alle 10
es braucht unser aller anstrengung ich
appelliere an sie halten sie sich an die
regeln
die nun für die nächste zeit gelten wir
werden als regierung stets neu prüfen
was sich wieder korrigieren lässt aber
auch was für möglich noch nötig ist
diese situation ist ernst und sie ist
offen
das heißt es wird nicht nur aber auch
davon abhängen wie diszipliniert jeder
und jede die regeln befolgt und umsetzt
wir müssen auch wenn wir so etwas noch
nie erlebt haben zeigen dass wir
herzlich und vernünftig handeln und so
leben retten
es kommt ohne ausnahme auf jeden
einzelnen und damit auf uns alle an
als heute vormittag die ankündigung kam
angela merkel werde eine rede an die
nation halten
wir dachten viele ist es jetzt soweit
kommt jetzt eine bundesweite
ausgangssperre wie in frankreich
die gibt es noch nicht merkel in ihrer
rede keine weiteren maßnahmen
angekündigt aber theo koll wird darüber
in berlin nachgedacht wird sie da was
wenn man etwas genauer nachfragt dann
gibt es diese stimmen selbst in angela
merkels eigene unionsfraktion also
abgeordnete die finden wir sollten
drastischer vorgehen es genauso machen
wie einige unserer nachbarn ja italien
spanien frankreich jetzt ja auch belgien
haben ausgangssperren verhängt die
kanzlerin hat sich dennoch erst einmal
dagegen entschieden offensichtlich auch
muss man sagen mit blick auf die eigenen
ddr erfahrung ist sie bei
freiheitsentzug zurückhaltender als
viele andere regierungschefs an einer
stelle der ansprache hat sie ganz klar
betont wir sind eine demokratie wir
leben nicht vom zwang aber es gab von
ihr auch eine eindeutige warnung vor
weiteren schritten im kern
hat die kanzlerin uns bürger quasi vor
die wahl gestellt setzt den ernst der
lage verantwortlich um oder es folgen
drastischere maßnahmen und das wäre dann
wahrscheinlich eine ausgangssperre
allerdings theo koll danke erst mal für
diese einschätzung
die vollständige fernsehansprache der
bundeskanzlerin können sie auf heute.de
sie eine erste ausgangssperre gibt es
übrigens bereits in deutschland sie
wurde in der kleinen stadt mitterteich
in bayern verhängt solche
ausgangssperren müsste aber gar nicht
nachgedacht werden wenn die gesamte
bevölkerung nicht ziehen würde wenn
alles ernst nehmen würden wenn sich alle
an abstandsregeln hielten privat und auf
der arbeit mindestens anderthalb besser
zwei meter
wenn alle ihre kontakte reduzierten auch
keine essens einladungen im
freundeskreis keine kleine familienfeier
nichts derartiges wenn alle unternehmen
prüfen würden wie viele mitarbeiter sie
in home office schicken können und auf
größere runden an konferenztischen
verzichten wenn alle alten und
gesundheitlich gefährdeten leute
konsequent zu hause blieben
auch der leiter des robert koch
instituts der obersten deutschen
gesundheitsbehörde warnte heute nochmal
nachdrücklich
wenn wir es nicht schaffen die kontakt
und in dem menschen wirksam und über
einige wochen nachhaltig zu reduzieren
dann ist es möglich dass wir in zwei bis
drei monaten bis zu 10 millionen
infizierte in deutschland haben mit
einer entsprechenden erheblichen
überlastung des gesundheitswesens wir
alle können dazu beitragen dass dieses
szenario nicht wahr wird
doch nach wie vor gibt es erstaunlich
viele menschen die um es salopp zu sagen
den schuss nicht gehört haben oder nicht
hören wollen impressionen dazu fangen
dort ferber eine runde basketball auf
einem berliner spielplatz corona
infektionsgefahr hier kein großes thema
da kann man jetzt nicht sagen
anderthalb meter voneinander entfernt
das funktioniert nicht was mich halt ein
bisschen wenn wir das sagen hat
was corona bedeutet das bleibt schwer zu
fassen
also ich glaube ich bin noch ein
bisschen zu blauäugig also ich hab so
ganz großen widerspruch in mir weil ich
lese die nachrichten und alles und jede
stunde pop irgendwas auf welche aber wie
durch berlin gehe sind immer noch leute
auf der straße und berlins spielplätze
sind noch weitgehend geöffnet mit
rücksicht auf beengte wohnverhältnisse
in der großstadt klar die abstands
empfehlungen design ein problem
also das kann ja in gewissen alter meter
fünfzig auseinandergehen klar durch
zwischenfall jetzt weniger leute auf
einem spielplatz zu
aber es muss ja jeder für sich selber
wissen wo ich sagen
mit den spielplätzen könnte es schnell
vorbei sein wenn es mit der vernunft
nicht klappt nordrhein westfalen wollte
auch spielplätze offen halten und sei
dann es geht einfach nicht wir haben die
spielplätze schweren herzens gesperrt
weil wir gesagt haben wir erkennen dass
es keine veränderung dort im
sozialverhalten gibt deswegen haben wir
alle die verantwortung
jede form von sozialkontakten zu
unterlassen die nicht zwingend notwendig
sind am rhein ist davon nicht viel zu
sehen
so schön das wetter zu wenig sichtbar
das risiko also mal so also ob ich jetzt
mich jetzt bei mir auf der arbeit bewege
ich arbeite jetzt persönlich mit vielen
patienten kontakt oder ob ich jetzt halt
hier draußen dann auch nach meiner
arbeit ist ein bisschen das wetter nicht
so lang was halt noch können macht es
für mich persönlich keinen großen
unterschied wir tasten uns daran soziale
kontakte so unterbrechen wollte ist ein
leben ohne soziale kontakte traurig
scheiße langweilig infektionsgefahr bei
jedem kontakt auch mit denen die gesund
wirken das ist neu und ungewohnt
diese situation macht natürlich auch
angst ja und der angst kann ich also
wunderbar begegnen die nehme ich das
einfach ignoriere
ja also ich schiebe das bag las er das
gar nicht an mich heran
immerhin das verhalten ändert sich jeden
tag ein bisschen in dem maße in dem sich
auch der alltag ändert wir wollen
sprechen mit dem virologen und
epidemiologen alexander kekulé er ist
leiter des instituts für medizinische
mikrobiologie des universitätsklinikums
halle genannt der professor kekulé
mitgenommen france lang
sie laufen ja schon sehr sehr lange
durch die landen und warnen vor diesem
virus wie erklären sie sich die
sorglosigkeit die man doch hierzulande
noch vielerorts beobachten kann
wer zum einen ist es tatsächlich so dass
auch die bundesregierung ja am anfang
das immer mit der grippe verglichen hat
und gesagt hat dass es nicht so schlimm
da müssen wir uns darauf einstellen
aber die krankenhäuser seien alle
perfekt vorbereitet und jetzt ist es ein
gewisses kommunikationsproblem hier
umzusteuern
ich möchte aber auch sagen dass wir
jetzt in einer situation sind wo es gar
keinen sinn macht nach hinten zu gucken
und zu überlegen wer vielleicht irgendwo
früher einreisekontrollen oder ähnliches
hätte verhängen können
wir sind jetzt in einer phase wo diese
pandemie und dieser ausbruch in
deutschland in einem bereich gekommen
ist wo wir eine exponentielle vermehrung
haben also ein punkt der der nicht
umkehrbar ist überschritten haben es ist
sozusagen eine minute nach zwölf und die
bundesregierung versucht hier eine
allerletzte maßnahme zu ergreifen indem
man versucht zwei bis drei wochen lang
die kontakte so stark zu unterbrechen
dass dadurch wieder zurückkommen in
einem zustand in dem wir vielleicht vor
einigen wochen waren dass wir wie man
das auch kennt aus den nachrichten wie
der einzelne fälle identifizieren kann
infektionsketten unterbrechen kann und
durch quarantäne und isolation was man
kann aber da müssen wir sie als
hinarbeiten und dafür ist es jetzt
notwendig wirklich eine nationale
anstrengung zu unternehmen
das wird aber nur funktionieren wenn
dann auch wirklich alle mitmachen und
nicht da denken das brauche ich nicht
oder es genügt wenn andere das tun
ein problem ist dass sich viele moment
sozusagen als hobby biologen im netz zu
informieren und da so manches zu dem
schluss kommt das ist alles total
übertrieben das ist nicht schlimmer als
eine normale grippewelle
ja das ist eben die leider die
verbreitete mehr ich sage es nochmal da
hat leider auch die bundesregierung das
gesundheitsministerium dazu beigetragen
man muss aber jetzt sicher ein paar
darüber im klaren sein wenn wir das in
den zwei wochen nicht schaffen dann
passiert das was der präsident des
robert koch-instituts gerade angekündigt
hat das sind die krankheiten und das
andere stelle ich mir so vor wenn wir
jetzt von ausgangssperren reden also
wirklich von drastischen staatlichen
einschränkungen was das für die familien
bedeuten würde mit kleinen kindern dann
zu hause zu sitzen und nicht mehr raus
zu können die polizei kontrolliert
draußen dass keiner das durchbricht
ich glaube da sollten wir tatsächlich
die chance die die bundeskanzlerin hier
ihrem eigenen volk gegeben hat und das
finde ich eine sehr positive
entscheidung jetzt zu sagen nein wir
machen das erst mal nicht und wir
versetzen jetzt noch einmal wirklich auf
die vernunft der menschen
ich glaube die müssen jetzt alle
wahrnehmen und es ist jetzt dringend
notwendig dass wenn man rausgeht dass
man das so genießt dass man mit den
menschen zusammen bleibt mit denen man
in der wohnung sowieso zusammen wäre
weil da ist ja die ansteckungsgefahr
nicht gegeben da hat man es entweder
alle zusammen oder keiner
und man muss wirklich vermeiden dass man
sich dann draußen mit arbeitskollegen
mit nachbarn oder zum fußballspielen
alles was eben näher ist als zwei meter
trifft
ich glaube das ist möglich ich glaube
wir sind ein kluges volk und ich halte
auch epidemiologisch überhaupt nichts
davon die menschen einzusperren
bei der in der sonne draußen an der
frischen luft ist es ja so dass die
viren ganz schnell kaputt gehen so dass
es eigentlich gut wäre die menschen raus
zu lassen und wenn nur ein paar
unvernünftige das eben nicht möglich
machen weil sie dann doch große partys
feiern weil die klubs geschlossen sind
und ähnliches dann wäre das ganz schlimm
wenn die ganze gesellschaft darunter
leiden muss die leute gehen ja auch nach
wie vor arbeiten und ist ja auch nicht
so dass jeder arbeitgeber schon
begriffen hat dass er seine leute nicht
mehr einen großen große büros
zusammenfällt oder andere mischen
konferenztischen versammelt
das ist ein ganz wichtiger punkt wir
haben ja vor allem das muss man jetzt
klar sagen wir haben ja einige bereiche
wir nennen das kritische infrastruktur
da wollen wir ja gar nicht dass die
leute zu hause bleiben wenn jetzt wenn
sie zum beispiel an krankenhäuser denken
polizei feuerwehr und so weiter da gibt
es ganz viele bereiche aber auch die
menschen die ganz normal in den
lebensmittelgeschäften sind die müssen
ja auch weiter arbeiten und da ist meine
forderungen wirklich dass man für diese
menschen ein ganz gezieltes
schutzkonzept hat das hat ja keinen sinn
wenn die kassiererin im supermarkt sitzt
weil die weiter arbeitet aber die nicht
einmal so einen mundschutz hat von ihrem
arbeitgeber weil diese mundschutz so
einfach nicht aufzutreiben waren da
haben wir dann an diesen stellen wo sich
die menschen ja dann alle treffen weil
sie einkaufen müssen und ähnliches haben
wir natürlich ein enormes risiko dass
dort keine krankheiten übertragen werden
wir müssen also die leute die jetzt
weiterarbeiten wirklich gezielt schützen
und auch für die gute programme haben
damit sie sich an ihrem arbeitsplatz
sicher fühlen es ist in einem satz
beantworten könnten wie optimistisch
sind sie dass diese ganzen maßnahmen die
jetzt ergriffen wurden auch tatsächlich
etwas bewirken
das ist ja sehr schwierig ich würde
sagen man soll den optimismus nicht
vergessen nie loslassen
die hoffnung stirbt ja zuletzt und ich
glaube es ist ganz wichtig dass der
optimismus auch notwendig ist dass man
eben nicht so verweigerer hat weil die
menschen die kein optimismus haben die
sagen eben okay ich mache einfach was
auch immer mir gefällt und es wird
sowieso alles schief gehen wir müssen
jetzt gemeinsam daran glauben und ich
bin ja selber arzt und ich möchte nicht
erleben was passiert in den
krankenhäusern wenn das nicht
funktioniert allerdings nicht habe sap
kunden danken für das gespräch sehr
gerne das gesundheitssystem wird
überlastet wenn zu viele menschen
gleichzeitig erkranken und es zu viele
plötzlich zusätzlich erkranken
neben all den anderen normalen
erkrankungen die es ja gibt was das
heißt kann man schon längst sehen
man muss ja nur nach italien blicken das
ist wirklich erschütternd was ärzten und
pflegepersonal von dort berichten was es
bedeutet wenn ärzte auswählen müssen wem
sie noch eine chance einräumen und
beatmungsgeräte geben
und wen man ohne weitere medizinische
gegenwehr sterben lässt auch in
frankreich melden jetzt die ersten
krankenhäuser überlastung an den
kliniken im elsass sind sämtliche betten
die stationen setzt die französische
armee hat begonnen patienten
auszufliegen und in andere landesteile
zu bringen bristol house berichtet
letzte handgriffe ein letzter check für
eine sehr spezielle evakuierungsaktion
ein fliegendes hospital der
französischen armee alt den
krankenhäuser dem elsass zu hilfe denn
dort geht fast nichts mehr in der klinik
von mülhausen werden der beim mehrere
patienten vorsichtig und unter strikten
schutzmaßnahmen transportfähig gemacht
sie sind die ersten die mit dem armee
flugzeug in andere französische städte
ausgeflogen werden
das ist für uns sehr wichtig denn so
werden betten frei für die vielen neuen
patienten die kommen
wir haben gestern schon neun patienten
den anderen kliniken unterbringen können
doch drei viertel der frei gewordenen
betten sind schon wieder belegt die
region contest zu der auch das elsass
zelt ist von corona besonders schwer
betroffen 1820 erkrankungen 61 tote
der infektionsherd war wohl hier in der
evangelischen kirche von mühlhausen
dort trafen sich im februar rund 2000
menschen aus ganz frankreich zu einer
feier
viele haben sich angesteckt von rw
billig und wir haben nicht alle
teilnehmer kontaktieren können weil wir
ihre adressen nicht haben wir haben die
mitteilung auf unsere internetseite
gestellt mehr können wir nicht tun
nicht alle hat diese botschaft erreicht
das virus breitete sich aus sommer ries
schwiegermutter hat sich in der kirche
angesteckt jetzt ist auch erkrankte frau
nancy komma sie hat eine woche bei uns
gewohnt und automatisch dann auch mich
und meine frau angesteckt seh barcelona
tropico krankenhäuser am anschlag auch
in colmar zu viele patienten es fehlen
desinfektionsmittel diese flaschen hat
der notfallarzt aus den wahllokalen der
letzten woche zusammengesucht notstand
seit drei wochen arbeiten ärzte und
pfleger rund um die uhr
und wir müssen immer hochkonzentriert
sein wir alle sind körperlich und
psychisch erschöpft
alle mediziner die können sind
aufgerufen zu helfen manche melden sich
freiwillig
ich konnte nicht zu hause bleiben und
abwarten wenn ihr alle überlastet sind
die not ist so groß dass das
französische militär jetzt auch ein
feldlazarett vorbereitet so wie dieses
hier in den nächsten tagen soll es seine
arbeit aufnehmen
die patienten die heute mittag
ausgeflogen wurden werden jetzt in
südfrankreich weiter behandelt es
dürften nicht die einzigen bleiben
wenn krankenhäuser kollabieren geht das
alle an auf menschen denen corona nichts
ausmacht können ja etwas anderen
schwerwiegenden erkrankungen oder sich
verletzen
damit möchte man nicht den überforderte
kliniken kommen auch hört man immer
wieder dass das virus ja nur für alte
und bereits kranke gefährlich sei doch
in jeder statistik stecken auch
abweichungen auf den italienischen
intensivstationen liegen keineswegs nur
senioren oder diabetiker
abgesehen davon ist das leben von
älteren etwa weniger wert es ist den
jungen corona partygänger egal wenn die
großmutter an den folgen einer saß kopf
zwei infektionen drei jahre früher
stirbt für alte menschen die
pflegebedürftig sind kommt aber noch
eine ganz andere sorge hinzu wer pflegt
sie in den nächsten wochen oder monaten
wenn die grenzen geschlossen sind
barbara lueg berichtet haustürschlüssel
eine ganze wand voller jeder einzelne
steht für ein schicksal teambesprechung
heute morgen in der ambulanten pflege
der münchner caritas die mitarbeiter
hier kümmern sich um 230 bedürftige
menschen in ihren eigenen vier wänden
halina stein ist täglich unterwegs immer
dicht dran an jenen die sie versorgt ob
sie angst hat in zeiten von corona ich
habe schon manchmal gedanken aber ich
habe noch mal so einen job und die leute
brauchen mich und ich bin da die
bedingungen der ambulanten pflegedienste
sind dramatisch schutzkleidung gibt es
kaum noch die vorräte reichen hier noch
für etwa 20 tage nachschub nicht in
sicht und wirklich hilfreich ist das
noch vorhandene material auch nicht
nicht wirklich
wenn es einen corona fall gibt soll
diese kleidung schützen
jako-o flächig aber letztendlich auch
nicht unter doch dass wir praktisch im
ständigen kontakt mit dem patienten sind
in der pflege bei der grundversorgung
ist dass nichts wirklich tauglich
so ausgestattet sammelt alina stein ihre
schlüssel ein und macht sich auf den weg
zu ihrer ersten patientin an diesem tag
mit handy und maske darf ich sie alleine
ohne kamerateam begleiten
in diesen zeiten ist das gespräch
wichtiger denn je für sehr viele sehr
wichtig dafür könnte in zukunft noch
weniger zeit bleiben denn rund 300.000
der pflegekräfte die sich in deutschland
um hilfsbedürftige zu hause kümmern
kommen aus ost und mitteleuropa
doch etliche dieser länder haben ihre
grenzen derzeit geschlossen viele
betreuungskräfte werden in den nächsten
wochen also gar nicht mehr nach
deutschland kommen
die folgen verheerend dass wir
sicherlich gar nicht möglich einen
adäquaten ersatz zu schaffen und es
würde meiner meinung nach dem kollaps
des pflegesystems in deutschland
bedeuten
alina steinmark an solche szenarien gar
nicht denken und konzentriert sich
lieber auf bernd und ingrid miete
die 77 jährige leidet an chronischem
rheuma halina umsorgt sie seit jahren
und so prägt das was halina in diesen
zeiten unbeirrt weiter tut vor allem
eins mit menschlichkeit während die zahl
der infizierten weiter sprunghaft
ansteigt zeigen die am montag
angekündigten maßnahmen allmählich aber
auch wirkung jedenfalls dort wo sie
umgesetzt werden
ob sich das auch auf die ausbreitung der
infektionen auswirken wird weiß man noch
nicht aber das tägliche leben und das
stadtbild an der metropole wie zum
beispiel frankfurt verändert sich in
normalen zeiten pendeln mehr als 370.000
menschen dorthin jetzt wirkt das
bankenviertel
fast schon wie eine geisterstadt
berichtet ingo klinge
leere und stille fast unheimlich wo
sonst menschenmassen bummeln oder
hektisch einen ist es ruhig geworden die
läden sind zu ungewohnt total ungewohnt
war hatte bewusst noch nicht erlebt aber
vielleicht denkt man mal darüber nach
dass es vielleicht nicht ganz verkehrt
das jetzt mal den arsch daheim zu lassen
ich spiele auch noch eine kleinigkeit
erledigen durch die frische luft dann
wieder nach hause
auch dieses leder geschäft musste
schließen ein altes frankfurter
familienunternehmen wolfgang gabler hat
gerade gestern nach einem umbau wieder
eröffnet und jetzt das man fühlt sich am
ende ganz einfach beschissen sie haben
einen betrieb wohl wo sie einen umbau
geplant haben haben sie lange geplant
und jetzt kommt einfach zu machen stehen
da und gucken sie sagen sie haben noch
berechnungen diese zahlen müssen und es
gilt was kommen müsste kommt einfach
nicht auch in den restaurants und cafés
ist fast niemand will die zarges und ihr
team räumen die tische rhein ihr
kaffeehaus goldene waage liegt mitten in
der neuen altstadt sonst ist hier kaum
ein platz zu bekommen
nun hat sie kurzarbeit eingeführt und
angst vor dem aus wenn jetzt verknappen
dreivierteljahr hier drin hat natürlich
auch viel geld investiert in den umbau
in die einbauten etc also jetzt noch
einen weiteren kredit ich ziehe den
alten schon ab also länger als vier
wochen halte ich es auch nicht durch die
pendler stadt frankfurt ausgedünnt wo
sonst die autos im stau stehen ist jetzt
freie fahrt die großen banken haben
teams gebildet die nur abwechselnd in
den türmen arbeiten am hauptbahnhof
sieht man vor allem vereinzelte
fernreisende und in den s- und u-bahnen
ist selbst zur rushhour nur wenig los
es ist ja ziemlich leer also
normalerweise ist hier crunchtime um die
uhrzeit weil halt jeder von der arbeit
nach hause fährt
ja ein bisschen bedrückend irgendwie
weil es sonst immer viel lauter ist und
wir haben an hat da so ein bisschen
angst schon fast die
verkehrsgesellschaft hat heute auf die
ungewöhnlichen umstände reagiert da hat
deutlich weniger fahrgäste unterwegs
sind haben wir unser angebot auch
eingeschränkt und das heißt wir fahren
ab heute nach dem fahrplan der für die
sommerferien gilt und der ist um etwa
zehn prozent gegenüber dem normalen
fahrplan reduziert die mainmetropole
macht pause wie lange ist ungewiss wie
heftig die wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen
dieser krise sein werden ist noch gar
nicht abzusehen
das kann schön werden immerhin es hätte
uns noch zu einem noch schlechteren
zeitpunkt treffen können deutschland hat
ja konjunkturell starke jahre hinter
sich
die kassen sind voll und die
finanzminister von bund und ländern
bereit da auch tief hinein zu greifen
wie sich die deutsche wirtschaft in der
krise aufstellt berichten alexander pohl
und peter meyer
es ist eine der letzten schichten bei
bmw am stammwerk in münchen vier wochen
wird hier die produktion stillstehen und
dennoch von den folgen des corona virus
will sich der autobauer nicht in die
knie zwingen lassen im gegenteil wir
wollen 30 milliarden euro in zukünftige
mobilität ausgeben für unser
produktangebot weltweit und daran hat
sich jetzt in der kurzen zeit auch noch
nichts geändert
doch milliarden alleine sind derzeit
kein wettbewerbsvorteil im rennen um die
automobile zukunft hat das corona virus
einen boxenstopp erzwungen vw opel
mercedes und jetzt auch bmw fahren ihre
fabriken herunter und das in einer phase
in der sich rund um das auto alles
ändert vom verbrenner zum computer auf
rädern fast 900.000 jobs hängen
hierzulande davon ab dass dieser prozess
erfolgreich ist
ich denke dass jeder automobilhersteller
der jetzt ruhe bewahren muss sich
strategisch überlegen muss wo will ich
hin
kurzfristig kann man weder das schiff
herumreisen noch irgendwie das ganze
retten sondern das muss man eher mit dem
zeithorizont von drei bis vier jahren
jetzt auch betrachten bei ihm geht es
nicht um jahre sondern um wochen
schreiner stephan wetzel hat all seine
rücklagen investiert um zu wachsen hat
leute eingestellt
ich weiß nicht wie es weitergeht ich
weiß nicht wie ich planen soll und ich
habe sorge dass ich relativ schnell
jetzt hat er doch dass ich keine
rücklagen habt mit dem programm steht
sorgen bereitet ihm auch der nachschub
an material weil viele seiner
lieferanten wegen corona schließen
müssen
es wird nicht nur seine sorgen in rund
einer millionen handwerksbetrieben
arbeiten über fünf millionen menschen es
ist der beschäftigungsmotor deutschlands
wir müssen schnell helfen es ist in
vielen betrieben eine frage von tagen
dass wir unbürokratisch und schnell
helfen mit den entsprechenden
liquiditätshilfen und auch mit der
entlastung von beschäftigungs kosten
vor welchen herausforderungen in
deutschland in den nächsten wochen steht
zeigt auch dieses bild arbeitgeber
arbeitnehmer der wirtschafts und der
sozialminister schulter an schulter
es geht uns darum dass wir möglichst
viele unternehmen und die das ja auch
möglichst viele aber als und
beschäftigungsverhältnisse erhalten das
sind schwierige zeiten für viele
menschen für unternehmen für viele
beschäftigte auch aber deutschland ist
in der lage das gemeinsam hinzubekommen
kommenden montag etwa wie das
bundeskabinett maßnahmen beschließen wie
die bestimmungen zur lohnfortzahlung und
kurzarbeitergeld ausgeweitet werden
können
da ist also noch einiges in der pipeline
vor allem für kleinere betriebe von
bethmann was ist da geplant
es geht um eben jene unbürokratischen
soforthilfen für viele freiberufler oder
die vielen ladenbesitzer die nun von
gleichauf jetzt vor dem aus stehen weil
sie bis auf absehbare zeit gar keine
einnahmen mehr haben werden auf den
deutschen einzelhandel auf die vielen
kleinen modeboutiquen schuhgeschäfte
buchläden parfümerien würde eine
insolvenzwelle zu wollen warnt dann
heute auch der branchenverband bdh de
die verfügten geschäftsschließungen
führten demnach bundesweit zu einem
umsatzausfall von rund 1,15 milliarden
euro pro tag oder 7 milliarden pro woche
ohne finanzielle hilfen sei das für die
meisten über mehrere wochen nicht
zustimmen so der verband
bundeswirtschafts- und
bundesarbeitsminister
werden sich also an ihren heutigen
worten messen lassen müssen für größere
betriebe mit vielen angestellten wurde
bereits jetzt entlastung angekündigt ein
erweitertes kurzarbeitergeld demnach
werden den arbeitgebern die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge in voller
höhe erstattet arbeitnehmer bekommen 60
prozent des ausgefallenen nettolohns
arbeitnehmer mit kind 67 prozent dieses
erweiterte kurzarbeitergeld hat sich
bereits in der finanzkrise 2008 2009
bewährt allerdings dürfte ist diesmal
für die bundesregierung ungleich teurer
werden denn viel mehr branchen sind
betroffen und viele firmen werden statt
nur einen teil wohl vielfach alle
mitarbeiter in kurzarbeit schicken
müssen
dankeschön frank und um nochmal nach
etwas tröstliches zu suchen in all den
schrecken
deutschland hat nicht nur wirtschaftlich
viel kraft haben auch exzellente
wissenschaftler die dieses virus
erforschen und eine regierung die
politisch willens und intellektuell in
der lage ist sich mit wissenschaftlicher
expertise zu befassen
dass das keine selbstverständlichkeit
ist zeigt der blick über den großen
teich donald trump wollte bis vor
wenigen tagen noch nicht mal erkennen
dass von diesem virus überhaupt eine
gefahr für sein land ausgehen könnte
entsprechend schlecht sind die
amerikaner vorbereitet
immerhin inzwischen es dort donald trump
im krisenmodus anders sein amtskollege
in brasilien unter den populistischen
corona leugnen ist präsident portion a
row gewissermaßen last man standing
christa vockerat berichtet aus brasilien
seine gegner nennen ist den anfang vom
ende der ära böhr szenario denn diese
ignoranz des präsidenten schockiert
brasilien 272 hände schüttelt er zählt
eine zeitung und macht self es als am
sonntag hunderte fans vor seiner
residenz auftauchen narzissmus huber
gesundheit über staatsräson
der gesundheitsminister hatte gewarnt
vor versammlungen und bei bio nano stand
zu diesem zeitpunkt noch das ergebnis
des zweiten corinna tests aus er aber
zeigt sich trotzig wenn ich sage das mit
dem virus ist alles übertrieben dann
gibt es schlagzeilen gegen mich
es geht ihm anscheinend nur um ihn
selbst im ganzen land waren tausende
anhänger auf die straße gegangen um
gegen die demokratischen institutionen
das parlament und den obersten
gerichtshof zu protestieren
das parlament ist gefährlicher als das
virus schreibt diese anhängerin
darüber kann francisco wie lehrer nur
den kopf schütteln in der favela goncalo
vor den toren rios machte er seiner
runden als sogenannter gesundheits agent
des ministeriums weil es hier kaum ärzte
gibt sind die menschen auf berater wie
ihn angewiesen
allerdings geht es nur noch um corona
mein zehnjähriger sohn will eine maske
kaufen er hat schon geweint mama wir
werden alle sterben aber wenn gott will
passiert das nicht
rios trinkwasser ist seit wochen wegen
defekter kläranlagen verseucht dazu
kommen infektionskrankheiten und
dengue-fieber die ärmsten trifft es
besonders hart
in saragossa da gibt es nur ein
krankenhaus dieses hat aber nicht einmal
ausreichende strukturen um jemandem mit
einem gebrochenen fuß oder irgendeiner
anderen krankheit zu versorgen
stell dir vor jemand kommt mit corona
jenseits des überlasteten
gesundheitswesens tod noch eine andere
katastrophen etwa 40 prozent der
brasilianer arbeiten inoffiziell
schwarzarbeit ohne jede sicherheit
sojamehl jan mit seinem kiosk am strand
wenn hier schluss ist weiß er nicht wie
es weitergeht ich habe kein anderes
einkommen nur das hier und davon leben
vier familien die strände werden jetzt
geräumt denn anders als der
staatspräsident hat die verwaltung von
rio den ernst der lage erkannt
einen plan b für die menschen die hier
arbeiten aber gibt es nicht millionen
der ärmsten brasilianer stehen vor dem
nichts wenn das öffentliche leben zum
erliegen kommt sie müssen weiter
arbeiten irgendwie damit setzen sie sich
aber auch weiter dem virus aus und sie
werden es auch selbst weiter verbreitet
ein land wirkt ratlos als am montag
wegen des virus die besuchs regeln für
gefängnisse verschärft werden gibt es an
mehreren orten revolten und ausbrüche
brasilien steht vor ungemütlichen zeiten
heute abend begann aber sogar wohl
szenario auf den wachsenden öffentlichen
druck zu reagieren in einer
pressekonferenz sagte er das virus
klopfe an
tür und es werden schwierige tage bevor
wir gleich auch noch zu anderen themen
als corona kommen fast victoria ries und
als panin check erst noch kurz zusammen
welche weiteren meldungen es zu dem
thema gibt angefangen mit den aktuellen
zahlen die zahl der korona infizierten
in deutschland steigt weiter
die johns hopkins universität
registriert heute abend knapp 12.000
infizierte
das sind über 3300 mehr als am vortag
insgesamt soll es in deutschland 28
todesfälle geben über 100 menschen seien
inzwischen genesen
[Musik]
das einreiseverbot für nicht-eu-bürger
zeigt wirkung
am frankfurter flughafen wurden
passagiere von mehr als 100 flügen
kontrolliert rund 140 personen durften
nicht einreisen
sie waren bereits unterwegs als das
einreiseverbot von der eu veranlasst
wurde
die airlines müssen sie jetzt wieder
ausfliegen
polen hat vier weitere übergänge für den
verkehr geöffnet angesichts der langen
staus an der deutsch polnischen grenze
wo sonst nur fußgänger ins land kommen
dürfen jetzt auch pkws die grenze
überqueren auf der a4 bei görlitz 60 km
stillstand bis zu 30 stunden wartezeit
der eurovision song contest wird
abgesagt das gaben die organisatoren der
veranstaltung heute bekannt er sollte
eigentlich mitte mai im niederländischen
rotterdam stattfinden
[Musik]
trotz corona es gibt auch noch andere
themen und ereignisse im überblick von
hand wolf im kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus und rassismus wird ein
eigener kabinettsausschuss eingerichtet
dass er das bundeskabinett heute formell
entschieden
nach dem anschlag von hanau hat die
bundeskanzlerin merkel einen solchen
ausschuss bei einem integrationsgipfel
vor gut zwei wochen angekündigt die
beteiligten ministerien sollen bereits
geplante schritte gegen hasskriminalität
begleiten
und es geht auch um strategien wie man
rechtem gedankengut besser vorbeugen
kann
das bundeskabinett hat heute auch die
eckwerte für die haushaltsplanung 2021
beschlossen die auswirkungen der krise
sind in den plänen noch nicht
berücksichtigt sie könnten derzeit nicht
seriös beziffert werden erklärte das
finanzministerium
vorgesehen sind nach diesen eckwerten
höhere investitionen sowie entlastungen
der bürger über die grundrente und den
abbau des solidaritätszuschlags
die sogenannten comex deals also die
mehrfach erstattung von steuern bei
aktiengeschäften sind nach auffassung
des landgerichts bonn strafbar das
gericht verurteilte im bundesweit ersten
prozess zwei britische aktienhändler
wegen steuerhinterziehung und beihilfe
zur bewährungsstrafen von einem jahr
beziehungsweise einem jahr und zehn
monaten
einer der angeklagten muss außerdem 14
millionen euro steuerschulden zahlen
durch comics ist dem deutschen staat ein
schaden in millionenhöhe entstanden
bei den vorwahlen in den usa läuft es
offenbar auf joe biden als
präsidentschaftskandidat der demokraten
zu beiden konnte seinen vorsprung vor
seinem innerparteilichen konkurrenten
bernie sanders deutlich ausbauen
in den bundesstaaten florida arizona und
erledigte beiden so die
übereinstimmenden prognosen der us
sender
sein das hat nun kaum noch chancen und
wurde von parteikollegen bereits
aufgerufen das handtuch zu werfen
und zum schluss noch die zahlen vom
lotto am mittwoch sie lauten wie immer
ohne gewähr
13 19 22 28 31 34 superzahl 5 und
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf seite
55 7
das war von uns mit einem
auslandsjournal spezial zur krise geht
es jetzt weiter
und um 0.30 meldet sich daniel
bröckerhoff mit heute plus und wir
melden uns morgen wieder auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
gute pflege zuschauer nur in der
südhälfte wird es morgen noch mal sonnig
und warm
wir haben eine zweiteilung wir unserem
wetter dieses wolkenband über der küste
unter der nordsee
das trennt eben die wärme hier über
süddeutschland von kühlere luft die
schon an der küste angekommen ist und
sie wird dann letztendlich am samstag
auch die alpen erreichen ja morgen also
deutliche zweiteilung bei den
temperaturen im süden mitteleuropas bis
zu 20 grad im norden sind es eben nur um
die zehn grad genauso wie in
großbritannien kühles wetter mit sieben
bis acht grad am wärmsten derzeit süden
von frankreich bis zu 23 grad und bei
uns na ja da ist es auch kühl in der
nacht aber frost gibt es nur noch an den
alpen dazu nebelfelder hier an den
flussniederungen im süden und im norden
regnet es immer wieder
ein bisschen und deshalb ist es morgen
auch erst einmal am vormittag genau
deutschland trübt dieses wolkenband mit
etwas regen zieht langsam weiter nach
süden
dann lockert schon mal auch vor allem am
nachmittag an den küsten und es wird
auch nur ein ganz schwacher wind aus
nord west oder nord ost südlich des
mains haben die besten garantie für
sonnenschein vor allem in richtung alpen
auch von einem wolkenlosen himmel und es
ist nicht nur herrlich sonnig sondern
auch warm von sachsen bis baden
württemberg 16 bis 21 grad im norden ist
es aber schon kühler mit acht bis 15
grad ja der freitag wird wechselhaft in
süddeutschland schauer und gewitter da
ist noch mal ein bisschen wärme dabei
aber dann am wochenende wird es deutlich
kühler es wird von norden auch sonniger
aber vorher in süddeutschland wird erst
mal schneien bis auf 500 meter runter
ich wünsche einen schönen abend und
macht es gut